[Music]
it's a race against the clock as new
mutations continue to evolve
health officials blame high infection
rates for the new strains
each new infection opens the door to
unknown variants
which threaten to undo the progress
there is now a clear real danger of
mutations making the virus more
transmissible
more little and more resistant to
existing vaccines
and we must act fast
understanding what's driving the viruses
mutations
a crucial next step in our race against
covet 19.
[Music]
new mutations have seen the virus spread
like wildfire in parts of the world
but more help is on the way the u.s
biotech firm novovac
has developed a vaccine demonstrating
almost 90 percent efficacy in a phase 3
trial
and proving successful against variants
it's the mutations that scientists say
we need to keep an eye on
last week eu authorities urged member
states to do more on sequencing the
genome of the novel coronavirus
the hope is that scientists can detect
mutations earlier
and keep track on how they spread
so far major new variants have been
identified in south africa
the uk and in brazil all of them are
cause for concern
as they spread much faster
the reason is a mutation in the
so-called spike protein
that helps them attach more easily to
human cells
the changes are not believed to cause a
greater severity of illness
but the higher rate of transmission
means more cases
putting even more pressure on healthcare
systems
in many countries there are already
shortages of ventilators
intensive care units and staff
plus slowing down the spread of those
new strains
would require even more stringent
lockdown measures
initial studies have shown that biotech
physics covet 19 vaccine
is likely to be effective against the
variant found in the uk
but scientists warn that may not be true
for the strain found in brazil
this subtype even seems to be spreading
in manaus
where seventy-five percent of the
population had previous exposure
to sasko v2
that could mean two things scientists
say either that people remain vulnerable
because their first infection was too
long ago or that the virus has mutated
to such an extent that it's resistant to
existing antibodies
virologists are still conducting
research into what that would mean for
the efficacy of the vaccines
if it turns out that they do not provide
protection against this new type of
coronavirus
the vaccines would have to be updated
the good news is
as the biontech fires a vaccine and the
one made by moderna
use synthetic messenger rna or mrna
they can both be quickly adapted
scientists have suggested
the changes could be made in as little
as six weeks
but testing the new vaccine and
authorizing it
might take much longer
paris sabetti is a computational
geneticist at harvard and was voted time
magazine's 100 most influential people
dr sabetti you sequenced ebola samples
from patients marking the first
in-depth use of real-time dna sequencing
in a pandemic
how's that changed our approach to the
coronavirus
um i mean it is it's a fundamentally
different world where
we don't six months after an outbreak
passes we don't find out what happened
we can actually
uh respond to it right away um
basically the genome of a virus is its
blueprint it's
how we track it how we diagnose it um
and how it
evolves over time so we want to get
real-time snapshots to know what the
virus is doing at every moment
and to constantly develop
countermeasures that target that virus
so we were too late did we miss the boat
i mean you sequenced ebola really early
on
um did did we miss out in this case
no actually we were very fast in our
genome sequencing the original discovery
of the virus
that was one of the really sort of sad
things about this is such a missed
opportunity because
we actually looks like we caught the
virus very soon after it entered human
populations and began transmitting from
human to human
the problem is that respiratory viruses
move quickly and so
even though we were very fast we had to
be lightning fast
and while the sequencing in the original
instantiation was actually where it
needed to be
our ability to then turn those into
diagnostics
well actually we did that quickly too
but then to get those diagnostics
everywhere in the world so we could find
it when it came
that was where we dropped off that's
where we missed the boat so
you know um the united states being a
famous
example of that you know going backwards
where we were just months into the
outbreak still didn't really have any
capacity to look for it
um and even had some regulatory
challenges and things like that
that was that was what needs to change
going forward but actually the original
sequencing was
right on uh we still there's a lot we
can do to keep up that sequencing to
figure out
as this virus has millions and millions
of chances to move
we need to keep up with it even faster
well the british brazilian and south
african variants were assigned to
specific virus lines but no direct
ancestors were identified
how's that problematic
you know it's it's just telling us that
we're not capturing enough information
that we
essentially uh we don't know where the
virus went first and and how it got
there so
we're still the thing is we're doing
more sequencing than we've ever done
before but we're you know in
millions hundreds of millions of cases
now so it's uh
it's a it's a whole different world of
how much you need to capture to really
see what this virus is doing um and
and just relative to the amount of cases
we're still sequencing very little
you've said we're in a race against time
as the virus may stumble upon a mutation
that makes it
more dangerous how much time do we have
it's hard to know um that's the thing
it's basically
no time we should move immediately the
the way it works is
every time a virus replicates and
transmits to a new person there's
opportunities for new mutations to occur
most those mutations don't have a real
biological effect but if you give it
millions of chances to happen even the
most rare event
can happen and so every every new case
is a new opportunity for the virus to
stumble upon something
you know and we're worried now because
the viruses uh
you know looks like it's more infectious
and looks like it can escape the immune
system
it could also change and somehow begin
to affect our children
we don't know where it's going to go so
we don't really want to waste a moment
to find out but he's a guest on this
show told me mutations work like
clockwork why then can't we predict them
better
well we can predict how often they'll
likely occur and what we can predict um
yeah we can we can predict essentially
like the they do work like clockwork or
a certain
every kind of every cycle there's a
certain opportunity for infections to
happen and so
we have a sense of how many mutations
will come we just don't know the
biological effect
we don't know we know some of it we're
learning we know we pay attention to the
ones that are in the spike protein
because we know that's going to affect
the
it's how it's going to infect cells and
there's there's different things we're
we're paying attention to but we don't
know the full biological logic of the
genome and how it works and which
exactly
it's going to have which biological
effect that's part of what some of these
studies are doing when they do gain a
function to try to see what
happens but those are those are
challenging for various reasons so
we're still not there yet but the more
we study the more we know and the more
we can predict
and when vaccinating how much higher is
the risk of a mutation if someone's
got the first dose but the second has
been delayed when when it comes to a
two-shot vaccine
you know we don't really know uh i mean
i think that um
the more our immune system bats it down
early the less chance it has to change
and so uh so you know the best thing we
can do
is to um prevent the best thing we can
do is to prevent infections
and um and to sort of shore up so that
our
infection doesn't go to anybody else so
you know those are kinds of the things
where it's like if our immune system
bats it down or if we quarantine well
and that new variant doesn't go anywhere
then that's the best thing we can do
parizebe from harvard thank you very
much for being on the show today
thank you
let me hand you over now to our signs
correspondent derek williams he's got
answers to your questions on the
coronavirus
if i get vaccinated is there a chance i
could still get infected
and infect others
yes to the first and um we don't
know yet to the second we'll have a much
better idea
about the dangers of both issues in a
few months
when when vaccination numbers really
climb
in in a serious way worldwide
um i think the confusion about this
topic is closely tied to how we use the
words
infected and infectious let's look at
the word
infected first it's used
in two different ways in its strict
sense
it just means carrying a pathogen that
causes
a disease but it's often also used
to describe symptomatically having the
disease
um and after exposure to this pathogen
you can theoretically be both
or just one you can carry soros cove too
and have symptoms but you can also carry
it and not have symptoms
maybe even after you've been vaccinated
i'll get back to that in a minute
but first let's look at the word
infectious
it means the virus is reproducing in
your body whether you notice it or not
and that you're shedding enough of it to
pass it on to others
we don't yet know if this is possible
even
after you've received a vaccine because
although trials
showed vaccinated people later
very rarely developed symptoms of covet
19
those trials weren't set up to show
whether they
also acquired what's called a
sterilizing immunity
that's when your immune response after
vaccination
wipes out any subsequent exposures so
fast
the pathogen never gains a foothold in
your body
effectively ruling you out as a link
in an infection chain but right now we
still don't know
if you could theoretically get infected
after vaccination
just show no symptoms yet still give it
to others
we'll have a better idea when we see
whether
large scale vaccine campaigns affect
numbers of new infections quickly
and dramatically
[Music]